[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream i think it's number
117.
that's right that's right and i
feel emotionally like 117 is entitled to
be prime but i think you told me it's
not prime yeah and not prime because
more things are divisible into it than
uh than one and itself and
it's such such as the nature of it's
primary reason it's not prime yeah today
this has been your lesson in why
emotions don't rule math
yes uh actually no there i think
actually
now that i see it i my lived experience
tells me that it is prime and that means
more now than it did a few years ago
indeed but your lived experience is
apparently full of crap
all right well i'll take that under
advisement indeed yes you're lucky
you're not a straight white male telling
me that or you'd be in trouble for some
reason
i guess i don't know i'm pretty low on
the progressive stack though aren't i
yeah you got
the doubled up x chromosomes going for
me yep that's it yep
that is it large immobile gametes and
that's about
about the one point in your favor and no
one checks
i'm speechless
[Laughter]
okay um hi everyone this is indeed
livestream 117 coming to you from march
2022 which means this is not the actual
anniversary but we've been at it for
almost two years
we we started in march of 2020 which is
and what a pair of years that's been oh
boy yeah so we will maybe say more about
that when we actually come up on the the
actual anniversary but for for [ __ ]
sake
sorry that's where we're going today um
now we're going to talk a little bit
about uh what you this week dubbed
vaccine apartheid mm-hmm yep and um and
inclusivity in all things except of
course
um
kovid
um we are going to talk a bit about how
we are being entrained to behave in ways
that are not in our best interests even
when those ways that we are being
trained seem neutral but being in
trained is itself a negative
you are going to talk some about uh the
the concept of gene therapy and what it
means
and about something that uh we thought
we were going to last week and didn't
circle back to oh i don't like that
phrase circle circle back yeah it's very
businessy it's very businessy well we
did not get back to um the question of
whether or not sarge ii was in fact
enhanced through serial passaging in a
lab would affect virulence and therefore
uh it's it's you know it's passage
through humans over time
um
and then we're going to
uh i'm gonna share an excerpt that i've
not shared with you yet uh that was
shared with us by a listener this week
shared with us by a listener this week
from orwell's 1937 the road the road the
path sorry hold on uh wig and pier uh
you will you guys who know
yes it's the road the road to wigan pier
uh really extraordinary um
observations of course orwell was uh an
extraordinary social observer observer
of so many things uh but the parallels
to
modernity are remarkable this is george
orwell not uh not larry orwell yeah or
lucas or bartholomew or any other
organization uh georgia's coattails is
that right yeah yeah i don't i don't
remember
it happened but it wasn't a big deal
okay
okay but before we do before we do all
of that uh
logistics we are on youtube and odyssey
for now the chat is live at odyssey if
you're watching live you can go there
and participate in that using you can
ask questions for the second hour
on darkhorsesubmissions.com
uh we a couple of episodes ago which was
actually i think closer to three weeks
ago
wow i am messing up my formatting here
uh put out a call for uh web developers
and as i mentioned last week the
response has been
overwhelming and fantastic and we are
grateful to all of you and as of this
morning uh everyone who wrote into the
darkhorse moderator gmail
address
should have received a response so if
you didn't if you didn't get that uh
check your check your spam or or
wherever you wherever you check
um to find such things
uh you had a patreon conversation this
morning wow yeah totally yeah um we had
a great conversation
about the um
amazing squid ink caper of 2022 wherein
anthony fauci and all of his cronies
seem to have suddenly disappeared
as uh war in ukraine changed the subject
for us
seems to be working out better for them
than the rest of us well we we will talk
a little bit about that but uh okay it's
quite the thing yeah but anyway you're
you do uh two of these to our um small
patreon conversations every month over
zoom i guess um and have been actually
since 2017 and then i was thinking it
was 2017. yeah and they have been
extremely popular and there are a bunch
of people who have been there
if not from the very beginning nearly so
um we've gotten to know and so and
you've gotten to know many of them very
well and we've come to know a few of
them and we've met many of them in
person in any case so you know we have
two conversations one is focused on
state of the world
uh what it means what we might do about
it and the other is focused uh more on
evolutionary issues more abstract
but anyway they're both really good
conversations and
people really seem to get a lot out of
them yeah so we encourage you to join
brett there on his patreon and my
patreon of course has the
monthly private q a which is uh two
hours as well but um us answering
questions that that patrons have
previously written in
more like what our weekly public q as
are
we have as always at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
various dark horse merchandise including
saddle up the direwolves we ride tonight
epic tabbies digital book burnings the
whole the whole lot
and of course um at i am writing weekly
at natural selections it's uh
naturalselections.substance.com uh
occasionally uh i have help from my
trusty epic tabby but more often he
shows up right here on camera as he is
right now
uh perhaps having heard the call of the
epic tabby just a few seconds ago i
think he's just lonely
that may be it this is a this is a very
cuddly
very very smart epic tabby all right um
we have three ads for you this week as
has become our want
and we will say before launching into
them once more that we are as ever very
grateful uh to our sponsors uh for um
for
helping us helping us do the show
helping us live our lives and just being
amazing we are um
as we've said many times we're very
choosy about the uh the sponsors that we
actually accept and so if you hear
us reading an ad for um one of these a
you'll you'll know that we're doing that
because it begins with a little audio
and ends a little audio and if you're
watching you'll see the green perimeter
on the screen
but no two that we are actually um we
are actually vouching for the products
that we uh that we advertise for you're
number three number three yeah i mean
you're number one in my heart but you're
number three today wow uh nice recovery
appreciate that all right
number three
number one this week is vevo barefoot
shoes made for feet most shoes are made
for someone's idea of what feet should
be and be constrained by and usually
that someone doesn't actually know feet
or what they can do if you go barefoot
in contrast nose feet vivo barefoot
isn't driven by fashion you can tell
because the shoes aren't really all that
attractive but man oh man are these
shoes of revelation now i will say
that i got stopped by two different
people this week um who were asking me
about my shoes and then um also i heard
from two other people who either have
just received or about to receive their
first pair of evo barefoots because of
our recommendation and um
and in
in the case of the two people who
stopped me and said you know do you like
those i saw an ad for those and it
wasn't they didn't know darkhorse um and
in both cases i said you know i love
them even though they're obviously not
that attractive and in both cases these
are two women they said oh actually i
think they look nice so maybe i'm
underselling them somehow even though i
literally almost every time i leave the
house in shoes and i do prefer to be
actually barefoot but almost every time
i leave the house in shoes at this point
i'm wearing these shoes we love them we
love them
it's their mental independence test how
they look to you oh you think i'm
mentally dependent no but i think you're
fearing that other people lacking mental
independence will look at these shoes
and think yeah but once you've no i
don't i don't think that's it i don't
know all right i don't think that's it
um they are incredibly comfortable
tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on is amazing they cause
no pain there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions in
fact one of the women who stopped me
said uh she she works retail and she
spends all day on her feet and uh
like you know i could i can go
you know well over eight hours without
uh without feeling pain in these and um
i could go on and on but this is an atom
stick to the script from now on our feet
are the product of millions of years of
evolution humans evolved to walk move
and run barefoot but modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and they are contributing to a
health crisis one in which people move
less than they might in part because
their shoes make their feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around at them
and
once people start wearing these shoes
they don't seem to stop and that's
really true so go to vivobarefoot.com
forward slash darkhorse to get an
exclusive offer of 20 off additionally
all new customers get a 100 day free
trial so you can see if you love them as
much as we do that's v-i-v-o
b-a-r-e-f-o-o
dot com forward slash dark horse i don't
think there is such a thing as a health
crisis i think it's an unhealth crisis
health is inherently not a crisis
okay
i just thought i'd it feels like it was
named by the same people who named the
gene eyeless because it produces eyes
and if you break it it
doesn't yeah no i see that you see it
yeah i see that i think the the people
who named the gene eyeless have a little
bit less power in the world but still
fahrenheit i'm just going to start
springless
unhealth crisis
as the opposite public unhealth policy
the opposite male on the head there
our second sponsor this week is relief
band a product that can help with nausea
under ancient circumstances nausea was
generally a useful signal that something
is off you eating something you
shouldn't have or we're near something
emanating a bad smell itself a signal
that you should not get near it in
modernity we still need to track our
bodily sensitivities we shouldn't always
choose to simply erase discomfort like
nausea whenever we feel it that said
some of modernity creates nausea that
does no good at all travel sickness for
instance can be agonizing and especially
if you're stuck and you know you're
going to be stuck on a bus or a plane or
a or or a boat or something
um
relief would be lovely and might in fact
be necessary just to get yourself
through it enter relief brand relief
band is an anti-nausea wrist band that
has been clinically proven to relieve
and prevent nausea associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
chemotherapy and more it's 100 drug-free
and can be used as long as you need it
developed over 20 years ago it is the
only over-the-counter wearable device
that has been used in hospitals and
oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting there are zero side effects and
now they have relief band sport a model
which is waterproof features
interchangeable bands and has extended
battery life
we asked a friend to try it out because
neither of us are particularly prone to
nausea everyone's got it sometimes but
we asked a friend here is her
testimonial i used to have naj on a near
daily basis she said from both anxiety
and the need to take regular medication
relief band relieves my nausea in less
than three minutes without the side
effects i was experiencing from
anti-nausea medication it has entirely
changed my life for the better she said
so if you've got nausea from anxiety or
car seasickness or something else that
you cannot otherwise disable consider
relief band relief band makes a great
gift for any time of year right now
they've got an exclusive offer just for
dark listeners go to reliefband.com and
use promo code darkhorse to receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee that's
reliefband.com
and use our promo code darkhorse for 20
off plus free shipping one last note um
relief ben makes a great gift for any
time of year that's part of that's part
of what i was expected to say and right
now i'm thinking st patrick's day
oh hell yeah when is that uh sometime in
march 17th 17th
yeah never a big holiday in our house
but you know no not at all that's kind
of like what holidays are in march so
people will have birthdays of course
roughly 12 of you um but uh a gift for
any time of year maybe just because i
was thinking of you i was thinking of
you and your nausea
and it made me think i'm not
we're not doing a good job no um but you
know for st patrick's day consider
getting
uh your friends relief banned all right
um what's up ned that is our third
sponsor third and final sponsor for the
week they are a cbd company final
sponsor forever after this after this
appalling reading um
they're a cbd company that stands out in
a highly saturated that is to say
dripping in cbd market
ned was started by two friends who
discovered that their hyper-modern lives
were leaving them feeling empty
bewildered and disconnected something
about this new way of life they say on
their website just wasn't working so
they started ned
you can buy cbd products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store but ned's
blend stands out their de-stress blend
in particular really impressed us ned's
de-stress blend is
a one-to-one formula of cbd and cbg
i always have to not say the name of the
nightclub when i read that
made from the world's purest full
spectrum hemp and also features a
botanical infusion of ashwagandha
cardamom and cinnamon
cbg is known as the mother of all
cannabinoids because of how effective it
is at combating anxiety and stress by
inhibiting the reuptake of gaba the
neurotransmitter responsible for stress
regulation
many of the cbd companies out there
source their hemp from industrial farms
in china just like the low quality just
like with low quality alcohol however
low quality cbd can have undesired
effects as good low quality alcohol
ned is usda certified organic all of
ned's full spectrum hemp oil is
extracted from usda certified organic
hemp plants grown by an independent
farmer named jonathan
in peonia where is piano uh colorado
also ned shares third-party lab reports
and information about who farms their
products and their extraction process on
their site these products are
science-backed nature-based solutions
that offer an alternative to
prescription and over-the-counter drugs
they are chock full of spec chock full
of premium cbd and full spec spectrum of
active cannabinoids terpenes flavonoids
trichomes ned's full spectrum hemp oil
nourishes the body's endocannabinoid
system to offer functional support or
stress for stress sleep inflammation and
balance
if you'd like to give that a try
darkhorse listeners get fifteen percent
off ned products with uh with promo code
darkhorse
um visit
helloned
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d dot com slash darkhorse
to get access that's helloned.com
darkhorse to get 15 off thank you ned
for sponsoring the show and offering our
listeners a natural remedy for some of
life's most common health issues
actually ill health issues there it is
yeah yep there are no health issues
this is going to be a long day
i apologize
not entirely in advance
mostly um really not your fault wow yeah
unfortunately because that maybe we
could do something about
well no i mean like you know if this was
one of us if like if we were
experiencing all of this be like you
know man it's me i got like i gotta make
some changes and then
it all gets better or you
and uh you know maybe we'd have a chance
if i was the cause of all of this i
would move out on all of your behalf
all right so um
it's been a couple of weeks
yeah it's been it's been a couple weeks
since
trudeau
implemented the emergencies act in
canada and then since uh it was it was
lifted and of course
he's doing a
typically political job you know he's a
he's a politician but he's doing a
typical job of pretending that was the
plan all along and it was never going to
be long term and um of course anyone who
is paying close attention can see a that
the emergencies act never should have
been implemented in the first place um
uh that the coverage um
that was largely
uh
uh boy i can't even think the word that
was that was facilitated at least but
promoted by uh trudeau of the truckers
and the other participants in the
drucker's convoy was uh was just lies
up and down and i i wrote about that and
had a lot of other people write about
that
on natural selections
and we talked about it for a couple of
weeks as well
um
and really
trudeau no doubt could see that the tide
was turning on him that um you know i
saw something social media somewhere
like
hey man
trudeau you seem to be the most hated
guy in the universe at this point quite
a feat uh you know it's it was it was a
bad moment for him and
he's disappeared now you know as
everything else has disappeared
well i did see this one very odd video
this week of him i i didn't think to to
uh cue it up for this you you didn't see
trudeau i don't know it's an amazing
video in which
if i'm understanding what he said
correctly effectively he starts out
discussing how there has been a
disturbing trend towards
authoritarianism
in many places and then he blames
misinformation
and basically says we need to crack down
more on free speech in order to deal
with the authoritarianism it was yeah um
well i mean
the guy you know i i i have yeah he does
he does have hutzpah um and he seems to
not um you know political death doesn't
seem to be a possibility for him uh you
know if if if anyone should be out of
office after this after what he has done
in canada for the last two years and um
and specifically over the last
what will be at this point six weeks um
it's it's him and uh he seems to be just
chugging along well i think he uh if i
understand correctly he is a member of
the
uh world economic forum's uh permanently
undead young global
leaders or something like that this is
how we pronounce the world economic
forum
the economic forum yes undead leaders
the permanently undead leaders that they
uh yes um and uh right
yeah well they're uh they're penetrated
cabinets as it were
that's quite an image
um
okay
so you know what what the freedom convoy
was
originally about most narrowly uh was
about the vaccine mandates that were
preventing uh canadian truckers from
crossing into
the u.s or maybe it was the opposite
direction because both the us and canada
had these in place
um and then you know of course it was
about more things than that um you know
so many of the of the of the bad
dangerous extraordinarily damaging
policies that have been in place in
canada and of course throughout many of
the countries including the us where we
live
over the last two years
but the you know but the the primary
thing at base was the vaccine mandates
and um
and then
we start to see
you know the cdc is sort of flustered
because that's their job now that's what
they do
and they start to hammon haw about masks
and we start to see mask mandates fall
except they're not actually falling now
they're falling in the future but at a
promised moment right though you know
the west coast of the us where again we
live
um you know got all got together
california oregon and washington decided
to lift mass mandates for most places uh
as of march 12th oh wait wait
as you alluded to it was initially late
march like somewhere it was the it was
yeah 2020 maybe something like something
like that and then as the
collapse of the narrative outstripped i
mean obviously there was no reason to
delay the lifting of the mask mandates
as soon as
it became clear that they weren't useful
they should have come down effective
immediately because of course there's
harm done every day that especially
children are wearing these things but of
course
even in capitulating they need to
reassert their power over us well by
setting these dates and then moving them
they are
hinting that they you know that there is
some
scientific reason which of course this
doesn't make any more sense than walking
to the table in the mask and sitting
down and taking it off right that's been
nonsense and the whole point and you
know the mandates people you know
whenever i say the mandates don't make
sense people say well
it depends what kind of mass are we
talking about but the point is
if the mandates aren't specific they
don't make sense even if there are masks
that do something they keep announcing
to us effectively that this is about
symbolism
and we're not getting the message so
this is all true um but i really
actually wanted to talk not about the
masks that i i think that the mask
conversation is yes still incredibly
stupid and all of what you just said is
true but i believe it's a faint i
believe it's a hey it's a distraction um
let us compel the vast majority of you
um who have um increasingly full access
to um
you know what they're not actually
privileges they're they're your rights
as as citizens of the countries wherever
you are
that we're going to pretend that the one
remaining artifact of this two years of
insanity is the mask mandates and
therefore as we either lift them or
promise that they are about to be lifted
you are now you are now back to to
full-fledged humans basically and what
this has done
is cause
essentially you know those of us
who don't have access to many of the
things that we had access to just two
years ago because we have rejected these
particular
vaccines as either necessary
or effective or safe in preventing uh
kovid
we do not have access to a lot of things
and i actually think um that you know
trudeau is an interesting place to to
focus here because he of course is
extraordinarily woke he's like you know
the wokest guy to routinely show up in
blackface that anyone can currently
think of um hopefully that anyone will
ever be able to currently think of but
he uses woke as as a as a as a weapon of
course as many people do
uh and he's simultaneously
um doing exactly the opposite of what if
you actually listen to the words of woke
like the honorable fundamentals at the
basis of social justice you know what
are those words that we hear diversity
equity and inclusion right and i was
reminded of this in particular and you
know the the phrase that i came up with
is it's this blind hypocrisy of the
diversity equity and inclusion crowd the
woke crowd if you will
when a long-awaited new performing arts
center was announced that it's going to
be opening shortly in the portland area
and i'm not actually i was going to show
the site and go through it but
interestingly they've been changing the
languaging on the site a lot in the last
few days so um
because i don't feel like you know
saying okay right now this is what it
says and it's going to say something
different
in in
a week or a couple of days
i will say that our local free news
weekly willamette week um
proclaims that this new arts center is
going to be quote a welcoming space for
all art lovers
a welcoming space for all art lovers
doesn't that sound amazing
i
got excited about it i thought you know
finally this is this is this is one of
the few pieces of good news um it looks
like it's in a great place it looks like
it's actually going to have a wide
variety of kinds of live entertainment
but a welcoming space for all art lovers
nope that is a lie that isn't a complete
lie because you go to the website and
you click on covet 19 attendance policy
and find the same web vaccine apartheid
now being practiced in um you know
in some cities across all restaurants
places like seattle and la and and new
york so i understand it it's not the
case in portland there are
there are individual establishments um
that are enforcing um
enforcing vaccine mandates at the door
and there are many that don't
um
and indeed like i said with regard to
this place they have they have flipped
back and forth between
saying vaccine mandates uh
absolutely that's it or
vaccine proof of vaccine or
a
facial formal negative covid test home
tests won't do
you have to it has to match you know
your id this that and the other and of
course these things are expensive
right in fact you heard a story this
week about uh someone who ended up
someone who doesn't have this money to
spend but in order to give her son the
birthday present that she had already
bought for him um i don't know i don't
know those birthday presents but uh yeah
the woman who cuts my hair uh wanted to
take her young son to a monster truck
rally which she wasn't really looking
forward to
but he sure was and then found out
having already purchased the ticket that
there was a vaccine mandate and she
actually suffered a vaccine injury
herself
um so did not want to vaccinate her son
which of course him being a young
healthy boy was the right decision yeah
but in order to rescue her tickets there
was not even a mechanism for an easy
refund um she had to get uh him
a test and of course and it cost a lot
of money i think it was 300 bucks so a
huge amount of money yeah and
um you know just the idea that they're
going to institute these policies
without
considering what this is going to do to
people who can't meet their
demand because of course at some level
the message is well if you can't meet
our demand for
uh proof of vaccination then you don't
really deserve our consideration that is
the underlying message that is the
underlying message and
this place
and other theaters which we have had
tickets to which i have had to cancel
have also been flip-flopping between
it's been vaccine mandate since the
vaccines have been widely available to
people or since the population has been
widely vaccinated but they've been
flipping between
vaccine or or your or you're out and
vaccine or a test if it matches you know
if it's pcr if it's within 72 hours yada
yada yada and um you know either way
it's it's untenable and it's hardly
about welcoming all art lovers is it and
it's hardly about inclusivity is it
especially when you take into
consideration
that
these are again
experimental treatments that are not
necessary for most people are not safe
for some people and have efficacy that
is dwindling by the moment and even the
cdc admits that now
and
just to go one step farther the fact is
the dwindling efficacy
um and
after a very rapid point following
vaccination the fact that these things
are not in any way preventing
contraction or transmission of the
disease means that there is no logic for
requiring people who show up to have
proof of them because it doesn't stop
these things from being spreader events
yeah it can't it the the idea that it is
about protecting other people that part
of the story has completely fallen apart
and uh if you want to focus on whether
or not you yourself are worse or better
protected as a result of having taken
this experimental treatment that is a
conversation that perhaps individuals
should be having with one another but at
the public health level the only thing
that that you know the the way that the
messaging has been has been pushed out
and pushed and pushed and pushed has
been about this being the thing that you
need to do for other people it tugs on
the heart strings especially the female
heart strings right it gets to and this
is what we hear also from mothers
telling their their children this is
what you do in order to be a good person
in order to care not just about yourself
in order not to be selfish in order to
be a member of the community who cares
about the people who cannot do this
these things and
that logic has completely fallen apart
and yet the messaging persists and this
is um actually
well okay go on but i i have a perfect
segue there to do what i wanted to do
next all right well i would just say
that the messaging
continuing on as if
the
uh
evidence had not shifted on these
vaccines
is
it is hard to avoid the interpretation
that something is holding on to these
mandates
because of their utility in manipulating
us and in turning us against each other
rather than their epidemiological
reasonableness absolutely and
that that is the thing that we have to
worry about because we are watching
across so many domains
uh rights that are
enshrined in our founding documents for
a reason suddenly under fire like we've
never seen it before
and you know this is happening at a
moment when mysterious forces who swear
that they are scientifically motivated
are being are functioning in a way that
cannot be defended on scientific grounds
and just so happens to have this other
characteristic which is
it amps up people's fear it turns every
person into a product placement for fear
right that's what the masks have been
right yeah we're all broadcasting this
be afraid message at each other even
outdoors which never made a wit of sense
um and so the point is it i think that
the whole system is like a more
sophisticated version
of what happened after 9 11
with the security theater
at airports and um
the uh the very the uh terror alert
system which if you ever looked into it
didn't make any sense on scrutiny right
it was really just a mechanism for like
amping people's amygdalas right when it
was politically desirable to do so and
the fact that it suddenly evaporated
without the change a change in uh the
the environment
suggested that this that's what this had
been all along yeah um i mean you and
you've talked about that before on air
here i do think that this what i'm
trying to say is something different
that we have talked about fear we have
talked about the use of fear
um and what looks to be explicit formal
and intentional use of fear now and uh
you know we have posited that um this
was in fact part of the plan all along
in fact there is some evidence from from
authorities in various countries that
they intended to use fear that they
understand that fear is a good way to
uh to change uh population level human
behavior and individual level human
behavior but what i'm what i'm focusing
on right now with regard to the vaccine
mandates is that this is all but
disappeared from almost everyone's
thoughts that unless you yourself are
affected by this
even if you oppose vaccine mandates even
if you
um
really think that this has the potential
to bring in authoritarian
horribleness
um you largely are breathing a sigh of
relief now like okay i already don't
have to or i'm about to not have to be
wearing these insane
masks anymore things are finally gonna
go back to normal and um in some parts
of the country of course things have
been more or less normal for more or
less the entire last two years and when
i say country i'm you know it's my
united states bias
but in some parts of the country things
have been anything but
and um and frankly it is
this is
a a more worrying moment in some ways
because
the the de facto privately instantiated
rather than government instantiated
vaccine mandates
are becoming normalized because they're
becoming invisible and we're not even
arguing about it anymore with the
trucker's convoy everyone was thinking
about it and they were pointing out just
how awful and divisive and nasty and
anti-democratic and authoritarian they
were and now we're not even talking
about it so i do want to please segue to
the thing that i was trying to get to
many many minutes ago
okay go for it i just want to say that
there it really is a tension between a
unifying force
and a divisive force and that what you
are pointing at is that even with the
lifting of these mandates there is this
divisive uh instinct and uh i will leave
it there and we can segue but um but it
is that tension and the truckers which
were portrayed as divisive or of course
unifying that's the point everything is
labeled backwards right the inclusive of
all art lovers thing is apartheid right
yes the truckers who were supposed to be
divisive were actually inclusive and
that's the thing is you have to get used
to a world in in which things are
labeled upside down because that's the
world we're now living in and that i
mean and that actually
that applies at sort of the individual
level of you know
we are not the first
to have said this and we've noted it
before here but um
individual
liberals and we still call ourselves
liberals but individual liberals as sort
of a class are much more likely to be
smug
and divisive and interested in mandates
that are exclusionary and certain that
they know you because they know one
thing about which you believe
and individual conservatives are much
more likely to be kind and generous and
open to all ways of life and actually be
interested in seeing what kinds of
connections can be made and you know
that's the opposite of
what we were told and what we thought we
knew growing up in the 70s and 80s
and there are certainly people out there
who will say yeah that's that's always
how it's been and it was only from
within the liberal bubble that you
couldn't see it and i'm sure that there
is some of that
but i also think the degree of smugness
and arrogance
and hypocrisy is in particularly fine
relief right now with regard to we've
now endured years
and the schools are failing and the
media hegemony is is
spreading yes misdis and male
information
in the name of diversity equity and
inclusion and these these are the people
who are spreading the non-inclusive yes
vaccine apartheid policies
they are the ones doing that
it is it is such a clear case of
hypocrisy it's extraordinary so
i wanted to just say something
about um
about how we're being trained
and
to wear masks yes for sure and uh to
ignore the unvaxxed and quietly just um
you know let them do whatever it is that
they do right the the dirty the you know
the
the non-compliant
the
we probably shouldn't be talking to or
about them anyway people the
eight-year-old who wants to go see
monster trucks the eight-year-old who
wants to go see monster trucks yes
um
but also and at one level
maybe less important but another level i
think may be more important and more
fundamentally even in
how we move and so i just have a
particular example that i experienced
this week but i'm sure
that other that many such examples exist
and if people think
about what kinds of places they've gone
in the last two years that they may be
able to find examples from their own
lives
so um
the portland has a world-class japanese
garden it's truly it's it's truly
wonderful
and it was one of the places that i was
spending some time early in the pandemic
um although pretty early on um
and you know and it may be gone once or
twice before the pandemic and when i
started going it was uh
they already had like mask mandates and
indeed at the point that they were
requiring masks outdoors i basically
stopped going because i
just
i could not take it um and you know
there are some indoor spaces there but
mostly it's a garden so it's mostly
outdoors
um but one of the things that they did
and this reminded me of like
early in the pandemic the new york
subway system cut the number of trains
down and of course what that did was
collect all the people who were on the
subway system into smaller into fewer
compartments which of course would have
spread any any pathogen more quickly
because people were concentrated and
they cut them down if i recall correctly
they cut them down to the local trains
right so the and there was some good
research that we covered early in in the
um
in the podcast on
uh indeed the local trains um you know
the the more tightly packed of course
and the more local the train site is to
say the more stops the more times people
knew people were getting on the higher
the rates of transmission worse so the
longer it took to get somewhere this is
actually where our model of uh effective
volume of spaces began with a discussion
of that uh surprising at first result
that this uh this
remedy that had been deployed across the
subway system it actually made things
worse um and you could see it in the
pattern of spread in new york anyway
it's very interesting and it really is
how we started
you know doing this was trying to
understand what was being revealed in
the patterns that people had found
i'll try to go back and find that new
york times new york times is that new
york subway research i think it might
have kind of
mit
if i remember yeah that sounds right um
and if i if i can find it quickly after
the shell put in the show notes but um
so you know the policy which was
explicitly put in place to protect
against covid was having explicitly the
opposite effect it was making things
worse covet-wise um and obviously for
people on the ground um not just because
they were more likely to end up with
covet as a result of these policies but
it was just harder for them to do their
work and those people who were still
having to go to work which is to say
largely not the middle class you know
information workers who got to zoom at
home but the people who actually had to
go places and serve people and do
physical work uh were you know was
taking them longer to get to work it was
harder for them to do so and they were
having to
um they were being exposed to more cobra
than they would have been if the if the
trains were all running
the policies the changes at the portland
japanese garden felt very similar to me
which is to say and you know at a tiny
scale and you know there's nothing
necessary about going to a japanese
garden so you know it's obviously not
the same at a lot of levels but
uh they closed down a bunch of the
trails a bunch of the smaller trails
and there's one little loop in the
garden um that's very narrow and very
steep and doesn't have handrails
throughout the way and of course the
japanese garden attracts people of all
ages and abilities and so there is one
little part of the garden that's always
a one-way path
um because for some people you know for
some kinds of people
meeting head-on on this path it might be
very very difficult to know what to do
or to be able to get by
um but the rest of the garden um had you
know it's it's a garden
it's not an amusement park right the
rest of the garden had always been open
to explore um as you like and the
policies uh were not just about masking
but they were um about some some number
of the smaller trails being shut down
which again would have concentrated
visitors into a smaller place but we're
outside so maybe that doesn't matter so
much
but they also put they made everything
one way so there was literally only one
way that you could walk through the
garden there were arrows on the ground
there were signs i had little enough
experience with this garden before uh
before covid that
um
it struck me as very strange for a
garden um but i came to know this garden
in this phase of its existence and so
i walked the route that they prescribed
that i must walk if i were going to be
enjoying the garden
and i did so some number of times back
in 2020
maybe even into early 2021 and then as i
said i kind of stopped going uh because
the idea of wearing masks outside at a
garden was
was too much for me
i went back this week for the first time
in a long time and um there's still
masks inside if you want to go to the
cafe or the gift store the um
they have a lovely um
a couple of lovely exhibits at the
moment
but for the most part again it's a
garden so it's outside and they don't
they don't expect you to wear your mask
outside although a lot of people were
um but more to the point for this story
the and so still some of the smaller
trails were closed which was
disappointing but there's no
there's no one way
one way anything except for that one
loop that i mentioned
and when i saw that i thought oh
wonderful i can actually meander and
meandering like serendipity are two of
the things that the the human brain just
needs to be able to explore and to be
able to create and to be able to come to
understand new things you need to be
able to meander you need to be able to
uh to experience serendipity it was one
of the the key words that i used in my
study abroad programs as as you know
right and so seeing that i was going to
be allowed to meander
was like
being told in a third grade classroom
you know not only don't you have a
signed seating but you're expected not
to sit in the same place every time
because even just having a different
perspective on the class on the teacher
is going to allow you to take in
different things that is that is similar
and it's kind of like
well no i won't go there um
i i was excited to meander
and i actively did so and i found myself
except when i was being actively
conscious at every turn that i had an
option
defaulting to the one that i had been
forced into before
forced into before i had been entrained
because almost my entire experience of
this garden had been walking the one
route that they told me i could walk i
got to see the same stuff for the most
part i could at any point stop and turn
around you know like you like you should
when you're you know on a trail or
backpacking whatever you stop and see
what it looks like in the other
direction because you don't actually
know
but
i found myself having to actively force
myself to take the opposite route even
though i walked into this place excited
by the possibility of meandering by the
opportunity to meander and still my
brain my feet everything about my body
wanted to just take the familiar route
this is how we're being entrained this
is a tiny example you know does it
matter that much not much but any moment
that you don't take the opportunity to
explore to meander to have serendipity
where you could just set and forget
is an opportunity lost
you were going to say yeah there are a
number of things here um
one i think you haven't given regimented
meandering and planned serendipity
enough of a chance
um no but really the the point is
you know i was having a similar thought
having nothing to do with the garden but
looking
uh i forgotten where where i was but
just looking down
uh a street and realizing that i don't
feel the same way about it that i once
did because there is now this sort of
cryptic uh
authoritarianism that
means that the way that you appear to be
free to use this place you are sort of
free you can go into a restaurant you
can order what you want
but the point is you're not really free
there's something that has become
obsessed with understanding you know the
limits of what you will contemplate and
controlling them and so it though
there is a kind of you know
a an amusement park
feels like a very spontaneous place
right you let out a scream because
something is very thrilling but the
point is that thrill was exactly planned
by an engineer who caused your g-forces
to you know rise to a certain level and
not to say that an amusement park isn't
fun it's not like it's wrong a long time
since i've been in one but i used to
love them as a kid but it's highly
prescribed and pretending otherwise is a
fiction right and if that's where your
joy comes from if there is some
authoritarian force deciding to create
opportunities for joy because of course
humans need them and so there's a sort
of plan for you to get enough joy to
keep you from revolting um
that ain't life and um actually that's
perfect but we'll wrap back up with
orwell at the end on that point yeah
yeah so um
you know it's it's a very
it's a very odd
moment because
you if you look for the thing that is in
training us as you say
um you find it everywhere
if you don't look you could kind of
convince yourself that things are
actually sort of getting back to normal
when in fact then the rights that we've
lost across these last two years are
profound and the rate at which they've
been lost across many different nations
it's not like one nation has lost its
mind this time right it's like there's
been a loss of our self-awareness across
the entire west and it's um
it's it's invisible
but the other thing i wanted to point
out
is there's something about okay a
japanese garden in portland oregon came
up with a system in which you walk one
way through its outdoor trails while
masked
now
and are thus incidentally walking one
way all right this is the point i was
going to make sure i know you were you
were going somewhere but the idea of
one-way paths is again counterproductive
to the point of the of the rule because
that guarantees that you will be in the
airflow of those excelling in front of
you right whereas if you can just walk
any which way it's you know a it's
outdoors so probably being even directly
behind someone outdoors doesn't make
that much of a difference but it's worse
than passing someone or from you know
going orthogonal to them or 30 degrees
or whatever
directly being in line behind someone
puts you at the greater risk of inhaling
something they just exhaled of course
right and so this is exactly what i
wanted to get in you and i make a point
in the book which
goes deeply into our experience as
professors and the point is
almost nobody who hasn't
interacted with the real world in some
way that the real world can cure them of
their
follies
has a deep kind of intelligence you need
to have
interacted with a system that will
make it clear that you are fooling
yourself in order that you get better at
not fooling yourself right
all of these systems
you know basically what we had is a
bunch of people who went to school in an
environment in which they got a's for
effort
deploying effort at controlling this
pandemic right now the point really is i
put in the time yeah i put in the time
and i came up with a plan oh what was
your plan my plan was to have people
walk one direction through the garden
while wearing their masks right
i spent all of yesterday at this and i
came up with something i think it's
really good what's good about it well i
don't know but it's really changing
people's behavior in a way that has
something to do with the pandemic right
and we do like changing people's
behavior don't we
so the point is it's like people are
actually convinced that the fact that
they've put in a lot of effort is
tantamount to them having done something
useful now we watched our public health
authorities if we give our public health
authorities the benefit of the doubt and
we say
actually
they were trying to control the pandemic
well then what they proved is it's
really hard this was such a contagious
disease that human efforts were swept
aside by this incredibly powerful
pathogen that you know yes we very
likely cooked up in a laboratory you
know from a natural ancestor but yes
turbocharged the thing and then the
point is human control wasn't gonna
happen right i did believe that two
years ago
what that they were really trying well
you know i don't think they were really
trying because i don't think they could
have failed as badly as they did but did
you but i know but i but i said i did
believe that two years ago i i started
out with
i'm not saying that i believe that that
was i believe now that was two years ago
are you saying you didn't believe that
two years ago um
i was a little bit agnostic but i was
certainly it was my assumption yeah and
then it broke very quickly and the
farther they went it seemed like trump
was just doing a terrible job and
yes trump was
reading stuff on the internet and
spouting off about it which is not a
good control mechanism but frankly it's
as good as anything that did so
um
but anyway the point is look so
you know in a world where you were not
led to believe that effort is what the
universe is monitoring right there would
be two questions okay we've got a
dangerous pandemic
what is the likelihood that by doing
something we will make it better it's
not obvious right
in fact i think the real
comparison that we need to look at is
what if i don't not suggesting you do
nothing you don't pretend that people
are getting you don't acknowledge that
people are getting sick right you don't
pretend that there's no pandemic but if
we had simply allowed
doctors to do what doctors do right and
let scientists study the thing and see
what they could figure out and not try
to rush in with a top-down plan that
turned out to make things much worse in
my estimation right we probably would
have done better but the idea that
we're going to control this in a useful
way all right we're gonna on whatever
organization you run whether it's a
school or a garden or whatever you're
gonna need to put in some effort right
that's how we're gonna control this
thing
um yeah and then everybody comes up with
their thing and basically i think they
feel rewarded
based on the fact that they know they've
done something and it has changed
something that they can see well and
it's consistent with the idea of work
being inherently valuable yeah right and
this you know i i quoted a little bit
from graber's [ __ ] jobs a few weeks
ago
and
and you know he goes into the history in
in that book and you know again it's
been a little while now since i read it
it's still sitting here um
i i don't remember all of it but you
know that's
that's not uh a universal from history
you know we didn't always assume
that you know
just
doing stuff that someone else is paying
you for
um is of value right and we seem to have
taken that on and i do wonder how that
interfaces with for instance the you
know ascendancy of the protestant work
ethic which
you know i wasn't raised by protestants
but um that was certainly you know that
was that was part of our home culture
for sure you know i was going to get a
job early and i you know and and you you
know in practice and you know just
working hard at things was how it was
that you were going to both perfect your
own
self and your skills and also therefore
make enough of yourself that you had
reason to expect that you would get
ahead right
all of these made sense but then the
kinds of things that i was doing and
that my family was doing uh were and i i
could be wrong about this but it all
felt like it was inherently of value
right and so much of what people are
being paid to do now and this is
graber's point with regard to [ __ ]
jobs which again he distinguishes from
[ __ ] jobs where which tend to be jobs
that are need to be done in the world
but pay terribly no no
[ __ ] jobs are jobs that need to be done
but tend to be tend to pay terribly and
[ __ ] jobs um about which the book is
written um are jobs that largely don't
need to be done even most of the people
many of the people doing them don't need
to know they need to be done but they
tend to bring white-collar wages with
them
and um the rise of the [ __ ] job is
uh a not just an absurdity
but you know maybe a contributor to the
fermi paradox frankly you know like
we've got a whole lot of people
like presumably the people making policy
at things like schools and gardens and
such
who are like oh boy we got to put some
effort in we got to do some work i'm
going to need that gold star stamped on
my forehead okay we've got a plan
well is it a good plan well but it's a
plan we've worked hard on it and we're
going to have to work hard to implement
it we're going to have to work hard and
maybe we'll come up with plan 2.0 at
some point but we certainly have to
implement plan 1.0 first so let's go
and it feels like
effort and effort feels like
it must be good
and it must not be good effort
there is nothing inherently good about
having spent time at something no and in
fact it's bad um
so two things one if you compare let's
take the japanese garden as a microcosm
right if the japanese garden had not put
in a lot of effort on a plan
it would have meant people would have
walked chaotically through the garden
where nobody would have gotten covered
because they were outside so the point
is you can compare these two things now
the one marginal difference
is their indoor spaces and those indoor
spaces it may have mattered you know
certainly a ventilation plan would
greatly reduce the chances of somebody
contracting it uh at the japanese garden
in an indoor space and you know the
three indoor spaces that i can think of
granted they're small but they didn't
have the arrows
you could walk chaotically in the indoor
spaces right so what they came up with
was a plan
that probably did no good changed a lot
of people's behavior
and i fi you know i
who reject in training so actively who
think about this i've been thinking
about this for decades
found myself in trained
which means i think i
because i am so aware of the hazards of
this and think and it is one of the
things that i think about a lot i think
it means that almost everyone will have
been entrained by things that they have
not yet seen or detected and that we
should all
try to become conscious of the ways in
which that has happened and break it and
this is you know harking back to wendell
berry's manifesto the mad farmer
liberation mad farmer's liberation front
that i read last week and then i also
posted on my sub stack this week um
you know do do something every day that
surprises them that does not compute
be the kind of person that does not
compute with some regularity so that you
aren't in trainable untrainable which is
which is why that scene that i've
mentioned in the truman show where
truman has caught on enough
that he becomes unpredictable and he's
driving around the roundabout and nobody
can predict which exit he's going to
take right it's that
um but okay i wanted to return to this
question about
you know
spending time is not inherently good
effort is not inherently good i once
surprised myself by
pointing this out i think at the very
beginning of
one of the programs i taught at
evergreen
and
i was shocked at my students reaction
because what i said
is that work is not good
and they were like
and i was shocked that this was
surprising to them because to me it
seems pretty obvious that if you have
two individuals who both produce
something of equal quality and one of
them has spent a quarter as much time at
it that that's actually the more
adept person and that we should all be
striving for a given level of product we
should be striving to invest as little
time and it doesn't mean that you don't
want to invest more time but it means if
you're going to invest more time you
want to get more out of it and so you
know it's it's a
the investment is a necessary evil the
point is
you we like people who work hard because
they tend to produce things but we
should not like people who waste their
effort okay but oh so you're going to be
misunderstood two ways i think
only two
well i i can see how i would
misunderstand you two ways
if i did not know you well and had not
taught with you in several situations
i'll probably forget one of them while i
speak to the first
um
the first is that
um
let's see you call it productive goofing
off is that what you call it uh you do a
lot of stuff you spend a lot of your
time
that to
anyone outside of you
looks like you're not doing anything yep
and um
zach is laughing you're like it's just
true i am not here slandering my husband
this is just true and it's real i mean
you've you've taken it to quite a level
um and you were actually you were
actually doing work you were actually
doing intellectual work
um and so you know
to to fit into your equation you kind of
you can't cheat you got to count that as
time spent oh right but it doesn't look
like what people expect you to look like
when you're spending time on a project
on an intellectual project so that's one
thing that you actually do spend a
tremendous amount of time but it you
know often it's you know the the
stereotype is like in the shower like
people have have their ideas in the
shower that's true too but you know
biking
or just fiddling
yeah here you can have that back
[Laughter]
uh yes occasionally i will take the
things you're filling with away
um because i can't take it
good lord um and your younger son has
picked this up hasn't again it's driving
me crazy so there's at least some
justice in there we were watching the
three of us zach was out doing tech
production on a play last night and uh
brett and toby 15 and i were sitting
watching a show and like
three times during the show i
carefully
reached over and grabbed the uh remote
out of toby's hand not because i want it
i actually don't even know where the
buttons are on and it's not backlit but
because he was messing with it and the
batteries were coming out like oh my god
you too just
stop anyway you are productive doing
this okay and you spend time in a way
that doesn't look like productive but it
is and so that's one thing
is that they you know they whoever they
are have an idea of what productive
looks like and it's mostly the kind of
thing that you see and again a third
grade classroom with people with little
boys and girls
and girls are much better at this than
boys are
sitting very quietly and neatly in their
rows with you know whatever it is
they're expected to have in front of
them and they raise their hand nicely
and politely when um they're called out
when they have an idea or they need to
use the bathroom and um it does a great
job of creating cogs and it does not do
a great job of creating
innovative thinkers and creators and
explorers and adventurers and
innovators and all these things that's
one
the second way that you will be
misunderstood
i knew i was going to forget it
is ah
we had a
we did in a couple of the programs that
we taught and i think i actually started
it um first in one that i taught and i
don't think it was as effective when i
did it alone is when we did it together
then uh called learn a skill okay
and uh learn a skill we we did this in
um
freshman first year programs and maybe
an all-year program i mean all level
program but mostly it was um
uh the the idea you know formally it was
remember evergreen was full-time program
so we had these students for um you know
either a full quarter or two quarters or
three-quarters but they're full-time
their full-time college experience was
supposed to be us and we'd spend
you know 15 to 20 hours a week in class
with them or you know all week if we
were on a field trip but then they were
expected to spend you know the
equivalent of a full-time job 40 hours
at at the work at the academic work um
of our program whatever it was
and so
learn a skill
was formalized like you know i had it
all written out like you will pick a
thing which has some physical uh
ramification in the world like carpentry
or playing the guitar or or
baking yeast breads i don't know
um and we had a list of possibilities
and we said if none of these appeal to
you um you know pitch pitch us your own
idea but you know we're not going to let
you just do anything because it has to
have physical manifestations in the
world it has to be of sufficient
complexity that you can't simply master
it in two hours right the key thing is
it has to be evident when you fail
right so physical manifestation of
manifestation in the world could mean
doodling but the problem is
it can't be subjective whether or not
you've succeeded at it yes and i i set
up a minimum expectation of hours per
week and it wasn't a huge number it was
like
i could go back and look but i feel like
it was four or something so it was like
over the course of a quarter just like
40 hours and then there were check-ins
there was a check-in uh midway through
the quarter public check-in like
everyone had to get up and spend like
one minute saying you know what it was
um how well they were doing and
and you know how how well they were
making progress on their own goals and
then at the end they got like three
minutes because we had 50 students and
we had other presentations like more
academic stuff as well
and the point was not
did you learn how to make a table or you
know did you learn your g chords
um it was what did you learn about your
own internal motivation
and you know did you in fact spend
the four hours a week
and
we asked for
we asked for we mostly got i think
remarkably complete honesty from
students even the ones who just didn't
spend the time because again
the point was and i think how i
formalized it in what i was what i said
to them about it was
failure is possible and fine
failing to fail is what we are trying to
avoid at all costs if you fail to fail
it's because you just didn't put in the
time and so this is where this is how
you're going to be misunderstood by
saying it's not about putting in the
time there are some things where you
really do need to
put in the time oh well no i i was very
careful i am not saying don't work i am
saying we esteem people who work because
work is important but it's a necessary
evil given that you are trying to
accomplish something the question is how
you know
the x is a something it may take you a
half a lifetime to do it right but the
point is it should take you a half a
lifetime because that's how long it took
to get there not because you wasted
three quarters of that time that you
could have spent on some other project
so it was like do enough work to get the
damn thing done
but don't waste your time at it which
actually comes with another important
lesson that i found students had a hard
time with which was there are a lot of
things this goes back to the question of
is there something useful to do
i would say
for me
the kind of work that i professionally
do my theoretical work
almost every
important success i have had in making a
breakthrough
involved
figuring out what the puzzle is
and then putting it aside and not trying
to force the answer because i didn't
have
all of the important pieces of
information to finish the thing until
later and so the point is if your point
is look i'm going to work on this puzzle
for two years
you may not be able to get to an answer
in five years in ten years it may it may
be that you're waiting for something to
show up to complete the puzzle and at
the point that you stop making progress
the point is i'm not quitting the
project i'm putting it on a back burner
and i will know when to pull it off that
back burner and revive it because now i
suddenly know the thing i didn't know
well and you were allowing for mental
meandering you were allowing for
serendipity you were allowing for you
know the you know the larger time scale
equivalent of dream space to enter into
your thinking and so you know in
academia
the the model that we are taught
that we are told in most fields not the
arts
is you know and not the experimental
sciences either but many many fields is
you have an idea you accumulate
everything that anyone has ever written
about that idea you become familiar with
what everyone has already said about it
and from there you cobble together the
pieces um you know the evidence either
for or against yours or you just review
what they've done and you create
something that's a little bit new and
you know over in science space i call
this brick in the wall science
um and you know it's it's valuable that
some people are doing brick in the wall
science but you will always have the
same foundation of the house that you
started with with brick and the wall
science and it's possible the foundation
of the house you started with uh is not
the foundation
that you want or that is true so you
know there's there's a problem with um
enforcing brick in the wall science and
um you know complete literature-based
review never shall the truth shall never
be outside of the literature-based
science
to the exclusion of all other approaches
because you can't have um you can't have
revolutionary ideas you can't have
paradigm shifts with that
yes in fact so
um this is a incredibly important point
you have to have people i mean there's
there's a way in which brick in the wall
science is a bridge too far i think for
anybody
but
it may but it's what most people do oh
it is certainly what most people do and
the point is it's actually antithetical
to breakthrough science if you have
everybody do it then there are no
breakthroughs and the point is the
bricks in the wall are less and less
meaningful if they are not stacked on
some breakthrough that's actually taking
you somewhere because diminishing
returns means smaller and smaller bricks
you're not really building anything of
value and so
it's a catastrophe
the whole idea of
well surely if you're going to make
progress on this set of puzzles you will
want to know everything everyone has
done on the way there and the answer is
by the time you learn everything
everyone has done on the way there a
you will have spent
a huge amount of time and made no
progress and b even worse you will be
entrained right you will be entrained in
the thought process that got them stuck
in the first place and this all
very counter-intuitive do you want to
know everything that is known before you
try to add anything the answer is you
probably don't you'll ask better
questions now you'll ask some bad ones
right you'll ask some questions that
other people have figured their way past
but you'll ask some good ones that
nobody's asked yet and that's where the
breakthroughs live so
it's all very counter-intuitive but
indeed well we could clearly go on about
this for a very very long time i'm sure
it is a topic we will return to
perhaps um since we've already been at
it for a while and we have several more
topics we want to get to
you would like to
um you had some a couple things you
wanted to talk about with regard to
um
mrna vaccines yeah
um
so i wanted to start and i
should have shown you this since we
can't hear the sound as a video are we
gonna watch a video that i can't see
yeah well i probably won't contribute
much to the ensuing discussion no no you
can contribute just fine i'll tell you
what it says um the video is uh
one of the high ups maybe the ceo of
bear corporation the
pharmaceutical maker
bayer or bear
b-a-y-e-r okay um b-e-h-r talking about
talking to some
group of people we can't see who they
are
um
about
the
massive transition that the vaccine
campaign has made in how open people are
to having gene therapy and his basic
point is two years ago if you had told
people that they really need some gene
therapy they would have looked at you
funny but now after the mrna vaccines
it's amazing 90
of people have some willingness to
contemplate getting a
gene therapy right and so anyway so are
you you want to show this yeah zach will
you show the video
uh we're really taking that leap uh us
as a company buyer
in cell and gene therapy which to me is
one of these examples where really we're
going to make a difference hopefully uh
moving forward there's some
ultimately the the mrna vaccines are an
example for that cell and gene therapy i
always like to say if we had surveyed
two years ago
in the public would you be willing to
take a
gene
gene or cell therapy and injected into
your body we would have probably had a
95 refusal rate i think this pandemic
has also opened many people's eyes to to
innovation in a way that was maybe not
possible before uh we're really taking
that leap uh
okay
so what i wanted to do was address the
question there's obviously been a whole
lot of
uh ink spilled
over whether or not these are vaccines
or not vaccines whether this is gene
therapy or not gene therapy now i have
pretty much avoided those discussions
because my sense is
they are
um
strictly a semantic question you deliver
me the definition and i'll tell you
whether that's a vaccine you deliver me
the definition and i'll tell you whether
it's gene therapy and the problem is if
we say these vaccines are gene therapy
that will cause people to think that
they are a lot more dangerous and if we
tell people they're not gene therapy it
will cause people to think they're a lot
safer but in fact whether they are or
not does not adjust their level of
safety at all right
and
this is an important point right and
this is a point that gets muddled by
postmodernists rather intentionally i
think the idea that language itself
changes underlying meaning
language can change the meaning of
things but applying different language
to existing things
does not mean that that existing thing
is a or b depending on whether or not
it's got label a or b on it right and
it's a classic estate tax yeah people
are in favor of an estate tax because
you're taxing the rich death tax sounds
like you're kicking somebody when
they're down it's the same tax
so
anyway what i wanted to do was just give
people an orientation so they know what
the question is and you can answer for
yourself then whether or not this is
gene therapy but the point again is
it's been used as a political football
uh rather than it being uh
right and i think even though rather
than let's let's put it this way i think
the fact that one can argue it either
way is the answer to the question this
is something very new yeah it's so new
that it does not clearly fall within or
outside the definition of gene therapy
and i want to just give people enough
information to understand what is what
is being described
so traditionally gene therapy which i
think initially goes back the idea is
sort of seeded in the 80s
it's a
it's a cool idea but i would say it's an
idea that is overly based in the drawing
in your textbook which is always
misleading right so if you think about
it
there are many disorders or diseases
that are the result of a gene being
broken in some way right your genes are
spelled in some way they produce
proteins mind you i will go back and
tell you that the word gene isn't very
useful genetic is a very useful term i
don't use the term gene very much but
i'll use it here just for shorthand
there are lots of cases in which a gene
has taken on a mutation that has
disrupted the production of its product
and made it harmful and if the product
let's say there's an enzyme that you
need to produce in your liver to
detoxify something and you have a bad
spelling of the gene that will interrupt
your ability to
produce the enzyme and to detoxify the
thing and if you encounter it that's bad
now in general
these things don't matter
every time because you have two copies
of every gene
and so
you know in many cases even if you have
a bad spelling if you have a good
spelling um
you'll be all right
but
when somebody comes into their doctor
and they have some kind of a malady
there's a fair percentage of the time
that
it is the result of the fact that they
have maybe gotten two bad copies of a
gene or it could be a sex-linked thing
where they only have one copy to begin
with and it's disrupted but nonetheless
there are lots of cases in which a badly
spelled gene disrupts your ability to do
something that is part of normal
functioning and it has left you
dysfunctional so of course
given all of the tools that nature has
built for editing
genes and
things like this
an obvious answer is well why don't we
just give you a good copy of the gene
and the basic answer to that question
and what i thought when we were uh first
hearing these ideas uh you know in
i guess we would have first heard them
in high school but college would have
been where they came up was well here's
the reason that that's not a great plan
it's that
you don't have a genome it's not like a
central thing that lives somewhere in
you that we can edit your 30 trillion
cells and you know yeah maybe if it's a
liver gene that we're talking about you
don't need all 30 trillion cells
modified you probably don't need all
hundred billion cells in your liver or
however many it might be several hundred
billion um cells in your liver but still
you gotta edit
awful lot of cells before you've done
enough work to actually solve the
problem even if the cells that you edit
work overtime
it's still a long way before you've done
anything therapeutic the genome is
highly centralized within the cell but
highly decentralized within the body
yeah that's well said
okay
so
the point is what gene therapy basically
means is
or at least initially basically meant
was you go in you edit a gene so that
the bad product is replaced by a good
product and you're no longer sick or
you're less sick
the problem is
easier said than done right we do have a
lot of tools for editing genes you can
do it in a cell pretty easily you might
be able to deliver it with a syringe to
a particular tissue but how much uptake
you're gonna get how much actual useful
editing you're gonna get and how much
will you know maybe you edit a bunch of
things well but in the process you also
disrupt a bunch of things that worked
because the editing isn't perfect
right see so anyway the point is really
cool idea
really difficult to do okay
implementation is going to be tough yeah
implementation is tough now zach do you
want to
put up the
fdas the fta has a little explainer site
uh what is gene therapy and you can
begin to see what the problem is do we
know if is this the modern uh version of
it and has it changed in these last two
years this is the current one i don't
know if it's changed but it's good
enough if it's changed it has not
changed in the waiting actually it says
content current as of uh july 2018. okay
so they haven't changed it then at least
if that's accurate
okay
so can you scroll down
okay stop um so there are a variety of
types of gene therapy products including
plasmid dna that is circular dna
molecules that can be genetically
engineered to carry therapeutic genes
into human cells so um
plasmids
are
outside of genomes they are little units
that carry particular instructions so
sometimes
antibiotic resistance in bacteria is
carried on a plasmid those plasmids can
be exchanged between critters
so that's
the introduction of it they're talking
here about introducing a plasmid that
contains a useful gene and not
integrating it into the genome
presumably
viral vectors now viral vectors are
capable in many cases of introducing
genes into a genome they can actually
edit things in that's one of the things
that many viruses do now it turns out
coronaviruses do not
but nonetheless viral vectors is a way
you could edit a genome
bacterial vectors bacteria can be
modified to prevent them from causing
infectious disease and then they can be
used as vectors to carry therapeutic
genes into human
tissues
now that suggests that they are not
editing
genes at all with their bacterial
vectors
anyway
well the point is this interesting i
wonder if that's an intentional use of
that word or if it's just
vagaries
i think the point is as with the word
gene right we define we used to define
the word gene and we said oh a gene is
that which exists between a start codon
and a stop codon right and it encodes a
protein we now know that that's not true
right there's something like an average
of five different edits that you can
make of what exists between a start
codon and a stop codon and so each gene
may have
multiple
productive interpretations right
you know i gotta say i uh this i've
never seen the site before and this list
of five so for those just listening
there's actually five bullet points and
you just read the first three
the fourth one is human gene editing
technology the goals of gene editing are
to disrupt harmful genes or to repair
mutated genes
and it it feels to me like this is this
should not be a uh unordered five bullet
point list but that um
plasma dna may be i know less about what
that might do but bacteria viral vectors
and bacterial vectors both could be used
to effect human gene editing technology
and indeed human gene editing technology
is the thing that people i think have in
their heads and they get scared about
when they hear gene therapy like that's
the thing they worry about most right
right and it's not like this is not
these aren't all equal it's like having
a list of hypotheses you're like no
those aren't alternatives to one of
these these five things don't strike me
as alternatives to one another even
though that's how it's being proposed
here well
i think the point is
you start out with an idea people have
bad genes that causes disease we'll edit
those genes and make them good okay then
you realize ah
that's difficult but there are a lot of
things we can do in that neighborhood
that might work
right like we could put maybe we don't
have to edit the genome maybe we'll put
it on a plasmid and we'll introduce the
plasmids and maybe we'll have to do it
periodically but you'll still be better
right
so
my point is
if you take a strict
interpretation gene therapy is the
editing of your genome to make you
healthier or immune or something like
this then these mrna vaccines are not
gene therapy if you take a broader
sensulatu
uh understanding and you say that
basically the point is what gene therapy
aims to do is to introduce a piece of
information into a body such that the
body is capable of doing something that
it couldn't do before that information
was introduced then in fact this fits
perfectly on that list and it does it at
the genetic level as opposed to like you
know vaccines are immune therapy right
like you never hear it called that but
that's what they are and you know if
gene therapy is any of these bullet
points on the fda then then yeah
well let's put it this way
the problem is that a vaccine that
introduces an antigen
is not gene therapy based on the use but
it's a mu any vaccine that is effective
is immune therapy it's it's affecting
your immune system
it's in training in fact your immune
system right effectively but i can make
it a good one that an attenuated virus
vaccine which is in fact i would argue
the gold standard of vaccines is gene
therapy by this definition and i'm not
troubled by that right just saying that
if the question is did you introduce
something in a genetic form
where the product is then causing you to
have some capability you didn't have
before right then you could make an
argument for that one and so this is why
it doesn't really matter right it
doesn't really matter but
is
introducing
a virus with
genes that then causes the virus to do
something that then creates immunity for
you
right is that
vastly different or is the plasmid
example vastly different than a lipid
nanoparticle covered mrna that gets into
your cytoplasm and causes your ribosomes
to make a protein as if your nucleus had
told it to no it's not different at all
this is gene therapy at that level and
so again but again who cares at the
level of the messaging right the point
is really what ought to alarm you is
that we are doing something for which
this is a question on which both
you could argue both sides
and what's really troubling here as we
talked about last week
is that okay
you're going to introduce something that
you know you're going to introduce a
literal genetic message yes it's rna not
dna but it's still it's a genetic
message you're going to introduce it
into the cytoplasms of cells so that
they will produce proteins that then
trigger something useful but absent a
specific targeting mechanism absence
something that tells
cells you are the cells that should pick
up this message and you are cells that
should ignore this message what happens
is you have to dump enough of the
message in that enough cells pick it up
to create enough effect to be worth
doing
but that means a lot of cells that are
not doing the body any favor by
transcribing this message are going to
pick it up
and that's the question the myocarditis
that we talked about last week might be
the hypothesis that i put on the table
last week was that the heart is picking
up these messages faithfully
transcribing them the way the designers
of the vaccines hoped they didn't think
it was going to be heart cells but they
didn't
provide the lipid nanoparticles of the
mechanism for bypassing the heart either
right so the heart picks it up
transcribes the message the immune
system looks at the heart transcribing
foreign messages and thinks that it's
virally infected and attacks and kills
some of the cells in the heart which you
can't afford to lose because it's your
heart and it's
not capable of replacing them with
similar cells
right so
that's the level of the hazard is it
gene therapy it the fact that it is
arguably gene therapy means that that's
the level at which we should be having
this conversation this is not
uh an antigen that was dumped into your
uh system in order to wake up your
immune system to a pathogen this is
something much more serious and novel
than that
and that's the conversation that needs
to be had
great
all right
um
you also wanted to talk about uh serial
passaging making
uh a virus in particular size kobe 2
more dangerous uh to humans or do you
skip it till next week
it's up to you it depends how long we've
been going oh we've been going a while
and i still i definitely want to get to
orwell because it fits with someone yeah
maybe i'll say here for next week all
right um
then
let me just
put my notes we're going to get to that
next week
um
this fits with
some of where we were starting
with regard to entrainment and such
um can't excuse me
uh the road to wigan pier is an orwell
book written in 1937 that i have not
read i read a fair bit of it this
morning but i won't claim to have read
it and so in general i won't read
excerpts from from books that i haven't
at least
well familiarized myself with
but an excerpt from the end of chapter 5
was sent to me by a listener in england
this week and um and he says
the listener in england says it's the
book is not the easiest read or listened
so far unless you have a particular
interest in the desperate life of minors
in northern england in the 1930s but
this passage near the end of chapter 5
stood out
end quote so before i read this excerpt
and again i have not shared it with you
yet
i want to just share a little more
background in the book itself as i
understand it again i haven't read it
but i've read a little bit of critique
and some reviews the first part is
orwell effectively acting as a
documentarian traveling through
england um
exploring the lives and conditions of
working-class people
in england in the 1930s between the two
world wars of course he doesn't know
that that's the moment he's in but he
knows he's post-war post war one world
war one and the second the second part
of the book which uh caused quite a
fewer apparently uh is effectively
orwell's um social analysis
specifically his analysis of whether
socialism is an appropriate answer to
the problems
of the people whose lives he's
documented in the first half of the book
and
in short
again i have not
i have not read most of this analysis i
read a little bit of it
his answer is he thinks it is
uh he thinks that socialism is an answer
um does have a chance of being an
effective solution but not the way the
socialists are doing it he he um has a
lot of critique
um
for both um the particular way that
socialists are doing things in the 1930s
and uh and
um more broadly for the ideology but he
does think it has a chance of doing good
and of course
um him having this deep careful and
nuanced argument uh manages to piss off
ideologues on both sides so you know
much
much madness ensues after he publishes
this book
um
here we go then without further ado
from chapter 5 of orwell's 1937 the road
to wigan pure just a second
before i read that was that um
thundering we just heard um our younger
son leaving on his electric unicycle yes
it was
okay oh god
great moment to start to have a cough
from the road to wigan pier
trade since the war has had to adjust
this is orwell trade since the wars had
to adjust itself to meet the demands of
underpaid underfed people with the
result that a luxury is nowadays almost
always cheaper than a necessity
one pair of plain solid shoes cost as
much as two ultra smart pairs for the
price of one square meal you can get two
pounds of cheap sweets
you can't get much meat for three pence
but you can get a lot of fish and chips
milk costs three pounds a pint and even
mild beer costs four pence but aspirins
are seven a penny and you can ring 40
cups of tea
all right
i'm gonna guess
what orwell wrote next actually i can't
really guess what orwell wrote next he
was too good a writer and frankly even
with a crappy writer that would be a
difficult job
but what i'm going to do here is
it's not entirely clear what i should do
here i'm wondering whether i should
switch topics to one of the other things
i wanted to discuss
maybe that's what i should do all right
so i will pick up the question
oh wait heather may be returning
you all right heather yeah
okay i was about to switch topics in
order
because it was hard to figure out how to
complete that yeah i'm sorry
um
we've both had a cough for a little
while here
but i think
oh it's dusty today
um
water is your friend i know water is my
friend water's also streaming out of my
eyes now because i'm coughing um okay
i'm gonna start that over
it's unfortunately a long quote and
reading aloud is not easy on the voice
but
here we go orwell's
uh 1937 the road to wig and pure from
chapter five
trade since the wars had to adjust
itself to meet the demands of underpaid
underfed people with the result that a
luxury is nowadays almost always cheaper
than a necessity
one pair of plain solid shoes cost as
much as two ultra smart pairs for the
price of one square meal you can get two
pounds of cheap sweets you can't get
much meat for three pence but you can
get a lot of fish and chips milk cost
three pounds a pint and even mild beer
costs four pence but aspirins are seven
a penny and you can ring forty cups of
tea out of a quarter pound pot packet
and above all there is gambling
the cheapest of all luxuries
even people on the verge of starvation
can buy a few days hope something to
live for as they call it by having a
penny on a sweepstake
organized gambling has now risen almost
to the status of a major industry
consider for instance a phenomenon like
the football pools with a turnover of
about 6 million pounds a year almost all
of it from the pockets of working-class
people
i happened to be in yorkshire when
hitler reoccupied the rhineland hitler
locarno fascism and the threat of war
aroused hardly a flicker of interest
locally but the decision of the football
association to stop publishing their
fixtures in advance this was an attempt
to quell the football pools flung all
yorkshire interests into a storm of fury
and then there was the queer spectacle
of modern electrical science showering
miracles upon people with empty bellies
you may shiver all night for lack of bed
clothes but in the morning you can go to
the public library and read the news
that has been telegraphed for your
benefit from san francisco and singapore
20 million people are underfed but
literally everyone in england has access
to a radio
what we have lost in food we have gained
in electricity
whole sections of the working class who
have been plundered of all they really
need are being compensated in part by
cheap luxuries which mitigate the
surface of life
do you consider all this desirable i
don't but it may be that the
psychological adjustment which the
working class are visibly making is the
best they could make in the
circumstances they have neither turned
revolutionary nor lost their
self-respect merely they have kept their
tempers and settled down to make the
best of things on a fish and chip
standard the alternative would be god
knows what continued agonies or of
despair or it might be attempted
insurrections which in a strongly
governed country like england could only
lead to feudal massacres and a regime of
savage repression
of course the post-war development of
cheap luxuries has been a very fortunate
thing for our rulers
it is quite likely that fish and chips
art silk stockings tin salmon cut price
chocolate five two ounce bars for
sixpence the movies the radio strong tea
and the football pools have between them
averted revolution
therefore we are sometimes told that the
whole thing is an astute maneuver by the
governing class a sort of bread and
circuses business to hold the unemployed
down
what i have seen of our governing class
does not convince me that they have that
much intelligence the thing has happened
but by an unconscious process the quite
natural interaction between the
manufacturer's need for a market and the
need of half star starved people for
cheap palliatives
the so
three things before you start riffing um
this sentence in particular whole
sections of the working class who have
been plundered if all they really need
are being compensated in part by cheap
luxuries which mitigate the surface of
life
that feels like today and that feels
like not just coveted times right but
that feels like um something we have
been seeing and talking about since
since we've known each other since you
know since high school
since the 80s um
i was uh i just i delved a little bit
into the fish and chips part of this
story and apparently fish and chips were
incredibly cheap incredibly cheap and
there were an abundance of fish and
chips stores in the 1930s
and it started to become more and more
expensive so that doesn't sound quite
right to our modern years in the 70s
apparently it started to get more
expensive um
but
but it was very much a
cheap thing that was available to
everyone
and then i also
um
i i looked i was thinking about a
conversation we had at the end of 2021
about the price of lumber we were told
by a contractor uh that dimensional
lumber like two by fours was about to
what did he say double
he didn't maybe have a prediction triple
s like that it had been it had been
going up and down during the pandemic
but it was about to really really climb
and so i went um and
looked it up
uh looked up the prices and of course
for some reason i don't have it queued
up because i wasn't prepared um
and this is
this is you could show my screen zack
this is the nasdaq's reporting on five
on lumber prices for five years
uh since
since i guess it would have been early
2018
and you see it start to spike
during the pandemic and it spiked higher
uh in 2021 basically before all the um
mandates were were lifted and then of
course we got them back and you know
here we go that's a match
um for what we were hearing from this
contractor just a couple of months ago
and you know do people need lumber yeah
people need lumber
but can people get
apps on their iphone for for dirt cheap
they can get those and they don't need
those the way they need lumber yeah and
in fact um
it's interesting
that
you know phones are almost the perfect
example of what's obviously not
essential for life since frankly we
didn't have them until very recently
um
but you know
there are a lot of folks who
uh don't have homes who have phones
right um right so anyway it's pretty
interesting
um a number of things struck me about
that one
very interesting that he makes the point
about
this having happened through an
unconscious process
so no doubt there's an awful lot of
collusion in our world
there's also an unconscious process that
does all kinds of heavy lifting for
those who would collude you know
perverse incentives that cause people to
innovate mechanisms
that they don't even realize what
they're participating in
i was also reminded
uh obviously
heller is much later than orwell
but the character milo minderbinder
in oro in uh
catch-22
um
such a such a marvelous exploration
because milo
starts out
as kind of a all-american
uh
go
go to it kind of uh soul who starts
making life better
for
the pilots uh he's in charge of the uh
the commissary i think and i think
that's right he starts making life
better by trading and he gets all sorts
of yummy things from other parts of
europe and brings them in and starts
making money you know because so he's
sort of like this uh you know shiny
uh
you know
emblem of capitalism
but over time as he moves farther and
farther down this road he becomes
diabolical he's in fact and he's and
he's specifically a luxury peddler
well and that's the thing so there's a
oh there's a marvelous exchange where
um
i hope i don't get this wrong but he has
made a bad deal and he's ended up with a
huge like warehouse is full of egyptian
cotton that he can't do anything with
and he tries feeding it to people and
they won't eat it and um
anyway i can't remember exactly what
happens i think somehow he's also traded
away
the
um the silk in the parachutes
so at some point somebody
jumps out of a plane with a parachute
but there's no parachute in it because
milo has traded traded it away and
there's i think he puts coupons in there
or something like he can you can trade
the person you don't have for their
ownership stakes in the syndicate
right that's right and i don't know if
you remember the exchange
that ensues after this i forget which
pilot it is yeah uh who has died
but
um
somebody i think it's jose and the sort
of anti-hero of the book
is shouting at milo for having killed
this guy by substituting coupons or
ownership stakes
um for his parachute and
milo's defense
well he died rich
and joseon says
it's not going to do him any good he's
dead and milo says well then it'll go to
his his girlfriend
and uh he didn't have a girlfriend then
it'll go to his parents
they don't need it they're rich
then they'll understand
oh
it's the most chilling line in the whole
book i think
the idea that that the rich would
understand why this parachute was traded
away and their son lost his life to it
and
yeah it's uh
it's mind-blowing but uh it's really
always interesting to hear orwell um
who basically
feels like he thinks way ahead of his
time and which is part of why the
present is so confusing because we are
seeing a lot of stuff that i thought
orwell overdrew but actually it's just
every bit as crazy as he describes it no
what i wasn't aware of i don't you know
i'm not a historian by any means i
hadn't really thought a lot about the
life that orwell lived i had thought
about his work um and you know this is
this is something we should be allowed
to do we don't need to become aware of
the creator behind works in order to
appreciate the works themselves and to
analyze them and and find value in them
but
one of the things that in my just tiny
bit of research i was doing on this book
the road to wigan pier this morning
that really struck me was that he
actually went and traveled and lived
among people whose lives he was then
telling
and
i would you know immediately i thought i
would
you know i in in a in a slightly
different world
um i would like to be able to be
um you know on a on a road trip now
much as i very much wanted to be in
ottawa during the during the trucker's
convoy um but actually seeing people
where they are seeing how they're living
and you know in in direct contrast to
the lies we are being told about this
being the greatest economic recovery
ever right um you know actually actually
seeing
seeing people um
as they are living their lives
and he did that and so all of his social
analysis
um was not armchair theorizing it was
not abstractions it was not and this is
in fact
what he part of what he argues in the
second half of this book as i understand
it
a little bit that i read
um is that the
you know the abstractions of the largely
middle middle-class socialists who are
insisting that you adopt their solutions
that will never work
are just that they are abstractions and
they're based on imagining of human
character and frankly human evolution
although that wouldn't have been
orwell's framing i don't think um that
simply misses the mark you know that
isn't that isn't true that you know
humans will not come to abide by the
rules of the white-collar middle-class
socialists um as they are demanding uh
that that people live by yeah that is
really the problem with it is um
there's an underlying game theory
problem right
it's a basically free rider problem and
socialism as constructed
effectively punishes contributors and
rewards freeloaders and so it's unstable
which doesn't mean you know
those who recognize some version of that
uh often overdraw the lesson of the
problem with it they don't understand
that actually
your body is socialist and a family can
be socialist
and there are places in society where we
want this you know the fire department
and the fact that it doesn't you know
look up your tax return before it puts
the fire out in your house or takes you
to the hospital right these are all
places where there's some element of it
that's quite right but
what i've tried to
later in life the model i've deployed is
it's not a question of do we want
socialism or don't we want socialism
it's a question of in this case do we
want more of it or less of it right it's
an ingredient it's not a plan yeah um
and
anyway i'd be curious to know uh what
orwell's point was about uh yes
socialism but no not the way socialists
think about it
i wonder what he was on about yeah well
i you know i'll add it to my stack of
books to read and
maybe get back to all of you when i when
i learn more cool
um
i think i'll also save this one last
thing maybe for next week because we've
been at it a while
and um
we have a q a to get to yet yes we do
right
so um we will
take a break uh just as you know as
short as as short as we can manage for
for tech reasons you can be asking
questions at
www.darkhorsesubmissions.com
[Music]
we will get to as many of them as we can
we never get to all of them we don't we
don't make that promise but um we will
pick and choose among the ones that
we've got and and see what we can do um
if you have logistical questions not
questions for us to
address on the show you can email
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
again consider joining our patreons um
looking up my sub stack
nationalselections.substance.com uh
where you can join for free and get
almost everything
uh to your inbox and um you know brett
mentioned our book on the show hunter
gatherers guide to the 21st century and
we continue to be really pleased with
the attention it is continuing to get
and we encourage you if you haven't to
pick up a copy either of your very own
or at a library and take a look and in
the meantime
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you